okay sam are you going to help me out
here or banjo
dude the banjo needs to be restrained so
i'm good were you were you joeing out
too hard man
showing out just joe it out hey you want
to joe out
hey you should ask that girl if you want
to chill out
just kick it off jake
[Music]
nico asked a girl if she wanted to joe
out
that's true he was talking about a banjo
he said hey baby if you want to joe out
context is everything context is
everything context is everything
context is everything so if you want to
go
out so that's the new term for the banjo
everybody i know
you guys didn't hear it that's because
it needs to be restringed
uh but that's because we were going out
too hard
we're jumping out too hard and the banjo
needs to be restrained so
i apologize um i i do have a pair of
banjo strings
somewhere in this room
once i locate them i will put them on
that banjo
that's great to hear jake yeah but
anyway yeah um
welcome back to the quarter cast i've
got the uh
ever creative ever talented sam gorski
ladies and gentlemen
give it up for me give it up for sam and
of course
the uh the effervescent
the the wise the nico perringer
the dastardly i guess you too everyone
clap ever
okay all right so illustrious and
uh regal jake watson hey thanks
thanks um
so guys uh wow uh wow what a d
what a year skywalker deep fake video
let's just hit on that real quick
yeah it did really well it was really
fun yeah
it was really cool and is that your wise
commentary on it nico like that's why
people listen to the podcast was
indeed did well i liked it it was fun
see you later
he asked me about a movie i'll tell you
about it uh
germinators terminators pretty neat
good movie saving saving private ryan
i'm surprised they didn't call one of
the terminator sequels terminators
i know like some of them come on hold on
do you want my insight to saving prior
ryan
yes please sad no
yeah if i was going to design a logo for
terminators it would be it would say
terminator 2
at first but then the two would spin
around
and make an edge james cameron pulled
that with aliens he didn't get to do it
twice
oh he did alien too and then he made an
s
the story goes it's a pitch meeting um
like so aliens written on the board
they're like
james cameron walks he's like guys i got
one thing
just one thing to make you green light
this movie he walks up to the white
board
he draws an s he throws a marker on the
floor and leaves like aliens
oh multiple aliens what a genius [ __ ]
and then they green lit wow so anyways
terminator 2 came around he's like guys
i got
that one lighter make a green light this
right away uh
uh uh he turned the s around and made it
a two
they're like it's fine we'll just stick
with terminator 2 for this i love those
i love you always on the couch hollywood
stories where it's like
hey yeah all you got to do kid is walk
into the pitch room
and turn that two around to make it an s
and then that's all you got to do
at the exact yeah you'll get all the
money to make terminators and aliens all
at the same time
when when in reality it was probably
like yeah so um
they already were kind of agreed on
making the movie and james cameron had
already done terminator
it was really friendly they were kind of
excited about his next thing
and they were just wondering what to
call it they just had a meeting about
that
let's not ruin the illusion okay sorry
you got to be a big shot
a-hole if you want to make it in
hollywood and you have to be very
theatrical with and with flair as we
have consulted
in our careers yeah gravitas
yeah that's how it made the movie
gravity
yep yeah actually yeah
all right this one's off to a great
start yeah
it is uh no but hey seriously uh just to
talk about that video for a second i
mean
uh we'd hoped that it would do well
um we felt like you know nico you and i
were talking leading up to it we were
talking about how
the deep fake was sort of evolving as
the weeks went on you know and we as we
were discovering
things about it and that's all if you
watch the video you can kind of see like
that's in there you know the first shoot
of dean
the second shoot of dean the haircut you
know the training throughout that entire
time the lighting
uh but it's always nice and reassuring
when you're working on something and you
think that people are going to like it
and then you release it and yes in fact
people actually like it um that's not
those two things don't always
yeah merge um so they did
on sunday and uh yeah um i'm just
i'm just really glad and happy for for
you and all the guys that uh
that worked on it thanks man yeah i'm
really happy with how it turned out too
and
i'm glad we got to like kind of double
down on it once we saw that it had
potential
also i saw a comment on the subreddit
where
like they're mentioning like corridor
has a very long history
of challenging wigs
and then somebody else has theorized
that dobie lives in wigs
we are we're wig challenged that's
there's no doubt about that
yeah um
very little you don't just buy a wig
that's perfect it's like you have to get
the wig and then like spend
time like styling it and you know it's
like it's a whole process
i don't how are you for that
just to get a wig that's made out of
human hair that
looks anything decent is like you know
600 bucks and then you have to style it
yeah if you're if you're asking which
wig was the bad one every wig
maybe except for the blackbeard wig for
the assassin's creed one but all but all
the other wigs in the assassin's creed
one were bad no
no blackbeard's wig was horrible too
okay okay so so all of them
back to my original yeah all right
it's all shiny it's all shiny and like
you can tell it's not real hair
okay okay looking at shadow of mordor
and like the main character is a wig
and like the prisoner's wigs are just
like the same way so it doesn't help at
all like
somebody's like so i thought the person
who were right into the woods and came
back as that dude
oh no that's exactly what it looks like
this dude runs off and like peasant
clothes and you know shiny black hair
and it comes back
messes him up he's like let me go get my
sword seriously
you can watch shadow of mordor and it's
a very like a very easy take away from
the story like
i bet you a solid 20 of people
saw the piece like that the thing is
that one dude just escapes
and he turns around like psych i'm a
badass
he's got a blue he's got blue on and the
same color hair when he runs off
yeah you know and then and then the next
person the next human we see
is a man in blue with the same hair
who's just transformed into a badass
you know you know like i was thinking
about this this morning it's like it's
kind of a tangent but i was thinking you
know like all these kids
school's not reopening for a lot of
people still and like
i was even listening they're like oh
yeah we're focused like the president's
like got a plan
to get people like 8th grade and under
in but like the
9th through 12th graders are kind of
like a non-priority right now for some
reason because maybe they're like
more social or something but i'm like oh
my god like
these high school kids so i was thinking
like man geez maybe i should just take
some time off
this summer or like in the fall and just
do like an impromptu like free film
course for
people who are like not in school or
something like that and i was like okay
what's
what's the how would i structure that
what's the first thing i would go like
alright would i get in the camera stuff
would i do this i like no i'd just be
like guys we're gonna learn how to make
videos today
step one they have to make sense
that's the first thing you have to learn
about filmmaking is you have just try
super hard to have it make sense because
that's like all it comes down to and
like i'm thinking about this wig
and like all the other moments like this
where we filmed videos and we're like oh
yeah and then we watch it and you're
like oh my god
like this literally makes no sense like
what
like i i remember having like nightmares
in like college or like even after
college waking up and remembering like
short films i made and going
oh my god that made no sense everyone
watched it and had no idea what was
going on and like i was like super
embarrassed and i'd always like
have like these you know anxiety
nightmares of like
yeah not the ones where you wake up and
there's you're late for the test you
skipped school and the test is
yeah like but it was like kind of real
though
anyways i was yeah dude that's so funny
it's funny because you're talking about
that in your uh functional filmmaking
episode
yeah you're talking about rule number
rule number one
is does it make sense yeah but seriously
it's like
rule number two is does it make sense in
the shortest amount of time
possible yeah i mean i think there's
some good stuff in the episode for sure
and and it's just like it's like if
you're gonna come at someone like hey
here's a video
like like what what do you you know talk
about camera aperture and shutter
speed and like it's like yeah there's a
lot of technical stuff here but like
most cameras have an automatic feature
you know
you hit record right just like but
does that random guy randomly transform
into a super
being like like on accident
you don't want to miss that yeah anyway
it might be in the lore there yeah
anyways
anyways tangents are cool um so we have
a topic today
yeah uh before right before we get into
it shameless drop uh i've been working
on a lot of music for a long time here
for a few years and i'm finally
releasing it and
basically i'm releasing one single a
week on my youtube channel and it's on
spotify
that's super cool so if you like the
last album go listen to it
i'm releasing videos and singles
everywhere for the next six or seven
weeks
where do they find that sam uh it's
youtube.comgorsky
or spotify just search for my name on
spotify there's a new song every week
[Laughter]
anyway um okay so the topic of today
uh nico didn't were we talking about
this
didn't this come up in conversation
earlier
or is this new i think this but anyway
here's this is uh you you
someone someone drop it drop it drop it
you probably read the title
uh when you clicked on this when you
clicked on this video uh
differently in 2021 if we were to start
corridor today what would you
what would we do differently all right
so we're all working full-time jobs
like maybe we're doing vfx for people
like we were jake
yeah i don't know you probably like
shoveling dirt
we are like are we our same age
uh as well no no okay if it if it was
like we're like we're in our early if it
was 2009
2010 except it's now 2021
yeah and we were a bunch of younglings
and we're like yeah you know what
maybe we should make a youtube channel
a bunch of young men out on our own
first time
real world wait then we look around and
we see the wasteland
we see a wasteland what of youtube
before us is there a green
sprout coming from the cracked earth
[Laughter]
and if if there is a green sprout what
is that metaphor supposed to mean
[Laughter]
okay let me start this off by saying
this first
i watched um the uh
veritasium video uh is success
work or luck the other day and uh
obviously his conclusion is the answer
is both oh wow
but uh yeah but um you're telling me if
everyone digs for gold
only one or two of them in that one of
his
one of his um ideas in the video is that
uh oftentimes people have a tendency to
just
obviously you see the world from from
your perspective so obviously
things that affect you more you're
oftentimes more likely to categorize
those things as being more important to
the outcome of a situation
like survivor bias or something like
that yeah survivor bias
no well that's yeah kind of that's
that's a little bit more
there's a few more layers to that part
but basically
uh the idea is um luck
is also part of success and i and i've
heard this said
as well success is 99
work and one percent luck but either way
however you phrase it and however much
luck is actually involved there
is always an element of luck
in in success and we found success at a
time
obviously we were all super hard working
obviously
you know it was something that we were
super passionate about
something that we were putting our blood
sweat and tears into
so you have to have that but we also got
into youtube
at a time when success
was a lot more likely than it is now
it's definitely a lot more attainable
yeah it was a smaller platform
there were less people on it there was a
lot more
elbow room if you would with respect to
how many
minutes of i mean the concept of minutes
per
or of hours per minute uploaded to the
site wasn't even it wasn't even a
concept at the time we started
yeah um and now you think about you know
there's what
what is it hundreds of hours uploaded to
the site every minute
yeah um well the thing is what was i can
i think i can objectify it
it's a lot easier to find something new
to do
on the platform because there was less
being done
you know you look at how youtube is
today and like if someone looks at
youtube and goes
in 2020 in 2010 versus 2020 if someone
looks at youtube and goes
hey how do i become successful there's a
hell of a lot more reference than 2020
for how to make a successful channel but
what that doesn't mean
is that's how to get successful
you know like and that's the kind of
like the this this this
this concept which i think a lot of
people really fall into when you get
really envious of something when you see
someone be successful
you you go oh well they did this to
become successful so if i do that too
success can come and like this happens
everywhere you see it everything like oh
i should have some guy made a million
dollars with a bitcoin
one many bitcoins made a million dollars
i should get bitcoins and then i'll get
them it's like by the time that success
comes around there's so many peop
it becomes saturated that path becomes
saturated
and the difficulty to use that same path
compounds
so many times that it's basically
impossible this is the hard path that
the burger king must walk every day
in the shadow of mcdonald's
in the shadow of ron mcdonald because
honestly when we so in like in 2020
or 2010 you know it's like we're like
hey let's make youtube videos how do we
do it
well hey we make goofy little videos
with our friends
we throw some vfx in there like that's
what we've been doing we're just gonna
do that
except we're gonna give it a video game
spin
you know it was really simple and we did
it and it was like oh people like to
watch this because
surprise there's not like people doing
it like we were doing that live action
video game concert
there was like there was like passion
projects short films for sure you know
like that's always been around like
hey i made a superman fan film has
batman films whatever you know
they're there you know but it was like
all right well those were like months
years apart for certain people and it
was like all right well what do we
how do we do this in the short term you
know rapid videos okay
cool well there is a uh i mean there's a
strategy that
you know this always applies if you if
you're a filmmaker and you're going to
ignore the strategy you're
you know you're asking for trouble but
you have to think about how are you
going to get people to watch it
you can make the best film in the world
but if you don't have any advertising or
reason or a hook for people to watch it
you're kind of wasting your time and you
know
that applies to every product ever made
especially filmmaking
products filmmaking is no different yeah
in that sense
there's there's a tendency to look at it
as art and obviously it is art
but there's a little bit of art in
almost every product
and in the the product whatever it is
whether it's a video
or a hamburger at the end of the day
needs to be appealing to
people yeah so that you can actually
have a
make a living off of it so you can
continue to do it you know
yeah also you're talking about luck and
the whole thing i mean not to get deep
into that but i just want to mention
it's not a thing that happens once it's
not like you just
you do all this build up for one roll of
the dice like you literally
you roll the dice every day all the time
yes yeah
i'm not trying to discount that and say
oh it was one one
luck factor like
think about situation versus success you
know obviously they both play into it
but people tend to think of it as a
a binary one-off kind of thing like you
know
for example oh you're lucky that you
guys found the react format it's like
yes
we are lucky we found that react format
but
we're not getting lucky every weekend
when the video hits a million views like
when you know when a react video comes
out this past weekend it's like oh you
guys got a lot of views in that lucky
it's like well
no it's like we're it's you know it's
a constant thing you know um but same
thing with like with opportunity like
you might miss an opportunity
but it doesn't mean that other
opportunities don't come up and just
likewise you know
we were in the right spot at the right
time in terms of our abilities as
filmmakers and as a kind of the digital
video revolution happened
right that's not to say that there's
still not constant revolutions happening
in filmmaking and in digital video all
the time you know so if you miss one
wave it's just like surfing
you know i don't surf but whatever it's
just like surfing if you miss one wave
hang out enjoy the sun it's a beautiful
ocean
and another one's gonna come yeah wow
yeah that's great
that's that's absolutely true and it's
hard to say you know there's a
there's almost like an inherent um
conclusion that you draw when you say
something like oh well uh you know
you were just lucky to be on that beach
on that day
to catch that wave and it's like yes
that's true but if you
what about all the other waves that you
missed on other beaches
that other people rode that you didn't
ride and if you missed that one wave
that you did ride
would you have gotten on another one and
would people have just said the same
thing
about that one yeah well you know
there's also an element of that in all
this too we're having a hypothetical
battle with people invisible
hypothetical comments as well
but like so that's what we do around
here i think okay so what we've
established this all right hey
we made youtube videos but what about
now like let's say
we're it's 20 21. number one problem is
how do you get notice
so back in the day in youtube it was a
lot easier to get noticed i mean
any platform you're basically going dear
mr google will you put me on your front
page for a little bit and show me to
some of your viewers
dear mr tick-tock will you please put me
on your front page and show me
some viewers yeah like every one of
these platforms you're trying to figure
out how to
let them put you in front of all these
millions of people going across the
platform that's true
so you're not really earning those views
yourself you're just trying to figure
out what keys you gotta turn to unlock
that door
to get shown to the eyeballs on the
front page of these big man platformers
big man
mr tubes you know like okay so yeah
back in 2010 that frozen crossing
video we released we got noticed
because well it got on to like youtube's
front page which
had way less competition
number one we got reddit some number
ones on there but on youtube we we
like they had like multiple slots they
had like most popular most viewed
whatever
then they had top for each category and
we managed to have like
our video at the top of like three
categories or maybe four i can't
remember
a bunch basically yeah youtube.com
there's like twenty-one
four of them are four of them are the
same thumbnail for our video
yeah and so it's like you're right
you're right though i think that's
actually a really good point which is
you know there is the like quality there
is the consistency there all is all that
stuff but it
there is that game still of like trying
to get
your piece put to the top
uh of of like whatever
list these sites have and like and
that's right
that's what i'm saying about the element
of luck and i i is i mean like
i guess yeah you're you're tailoring
you're tailoring knowing what the what
the intended and hopeful
outcome is but at the same time like
you know just being watched and shared
by somebody else's account
being watched and shared by x other
account you know
being hashtagged here yeah reese
retweeted here like all of those little
things
are part of that and and that's a result
of obviously consistency and quality
yeah but also of of of of an intangible
well and you know right now it's like if
so 2021 strategies
it's still the same though except now
you're basically facing the quote
unquote algorithm which is like how do i
get this thing algorithm to share my
videos for me
and put them in front of other people
yeah
and like and that's really truly what it
is and i'm starting to realize that like
a lot of the cool stuff i've seen and
just quote unquote discovered
over the last year two three years is
stuff that the algorithm pushed
to me and it happened recently um
like a week or two ago i saw a video
that got popped up on my feet it was a
weird animation
and i watched it it's like about like
it's like a joke about like rpg games
but it was done with a really cool style
and while watching it like
hey this is pretty sweet this is a
really cool video and i check out the
guy's youtube channel
i start watching his other videos i'm
like wow all his videos are great they
all have like 20 30k views on them
like this isn't like this guy is so
massively talented
and then i think i started sharing with
you guys and i said
the channel was joel haver is the guy's
youtube channel
and he's just like he's a filmmaker who
makes a dumb little video every week
and they're hilarious and like he's
really talented because they're like
they balance like
great sketch comedy they're really
bite-sized
simple he put some interesting like
artistic
ideas behind them as well that really
speak to
like a level of creativity that i i
haven't seen
and so so so i mean they're genuinely
good and they're genuinely
interesting funny and relatively
innovative there's an artful touch to
them
but the point is the freaking algorithm
gave it to me and
and and at the the craziest part about
this
is i send them to you jake and you're
like oh wow yeah he got a lot of
subscribers
recently and i look yeah and
when i was watching these videos i was
watching them in the middle
of a massive 400 000
subscriber spike his youtube channel was
encountering over the course
of less than a month he went from like a
hundred thousand subscribers to
i don't even know what he's at right now
last time i checked it was like 500
something thousand subscribers
yeah and and it was this rapid explosion
where somehow the youtube algorithm
handed it handed a video it was like
let's
let's give this guy a chance and put one
video out there and
it's it just lit a fire suddenly people
are flooding to this youtube channel and
and my reaction i'm sure was the same as
everyone else they watch and go like wow
actually this is legitimately good
this is he's legitimately talented these
are really entertaining
videos and the algorithm just took that
that engagement and just
kept pushing and pushing pushing pushing
to more and more people
and so like it's just crazy he's been
putting videos out for like three years
almost like one once a week okay
i have a thought on this it's absolutely
insane but
yeah is that different
or just an incredibly innovative modern
way
to do the exact same thing that humans
have done
in the arts industries throughout the
20th century
i think it's kind of the same thing i
mean all of it boils down to you make
your work you make your work you make
your work and then
if it's been consistently good for long
enough you'll get noticed because
everybody everybody knows that time when
you discover a new artist
whether it's video or music or what have
you
you haven't heard of them before and
then you discover them and you're like
holy [ __ ] these this person or these
people or whatever are awesome
and you you blaze through their catalog
and you
you know and it's like invigorating and
it's inspiring
you know and then it makes you want to
like go out and do more
like that that that like discovery
you know is now happening in a
in part in a large part a
machine assisted yeah it's just
unfortunate because machine assisting
is still so wonky like i'm not saying
that algorithms are bad but just like
there isn't a way for you to discover
things that aren't in your wheelhouse
right now
there's like algorithms not programmed
to be like i'm just gonna throw this
random thing at this person other people
like it but it's definitely not what
they're into but maybe they'll like it
like you never get any of that and so
like like but how do you discover
something new then how do you discover a
new sound a new style a new genre
because
you know let's say let's say i invented
all right guys
you've heard of sci-fi you've heard of
fantasy but you haven't heard
of uh
medieval fantasy hyper real it's a new
genre that i
that i've invented sure sure are you but
haven't you said it before like well now
you're not a list nothing can recommend
you like you know how to get out there
but at the same time
you need to do something new to get
noticed
you got to pull the joel haber man you
got to grind for one of the tricky
balances
you know yeah for all that stuff you
can't rely on like a machine
you know what i mean like you're like
well how did you do how did you used to
do it
um yeah i mean there's no cure for that
i guess well let's return to the prom
for a second here so if we're starting
the youtube channel now in 2021
i mean the first thing to do is identify
what do you
actually want to do do you want to make
videos do you want to make music or do
you just want to be famous
you know like what is it that you
actually truly want are you just looking
for an income
are you looking to tell a story and you
know what it's probably not going to be
one thing because all these things are
nuanced you know what chances are you
probably want to make money
and make videos you probably want to be
able to buy your groceries and do your
art at the same time
but you know there's definitely a
balance of that and you have to identify
what you're doing
and the question is is youtube even the
right spot for it you know really
youtube isn't even really the right spot
for corridor like
we're such an anomaly on this dang video
platform
like everything else on youtube is very
much
like personality driven it's very like
it's much younger audience i think than
what we generally are i think we hit
young audiences but we're much more like
broad
across all ages and there's a lot of
yeah there's there's some there's art on
the platform
yeah it's just like it's not obviously
it's not like what the platform is
dominated
with just like how tv has sitcoms you
know it's like
yeah it's you don't have sitcoms on
youtube there's no reason why you
shouldn't
have be able to have sitcoms on youtube
but there aren't sitcoms on youtube you
know so it's like
if somebody came out with a sitcom on
youtube and it did well and they're
getting views they'd be like cool that's
really neat there's a sitcom on youtube
not really the platform for it but what
the heck i'll watch it here you know
it's like
that's how i feel about the corridor
videos we make to some extent
and i think we have found that balance
with the chord or crew where we found
the format of
youtube and like the genre of youtube
and married it with our style
but if you're trying to start a youtube
channel these days
you know i guess the question is like if
you're trying to start anything these
days you have to kind of first figure
out your platform but then let's say
it's youtube i guess you'd have to kind
of ask like what is it that you're
trying to do like if you're trying to
run a cooking show
maybe youtube works but maybe tick tock
is better
maybe facebook is better you know you
have to kind of figure out your platform
but the other thing i think is just
what is it that you're doing that's
special
what is it that you're doing that's
unique and then how can you leverage
that
into getting people to notice yeah and
so but sometimes you have to just trust
that you're doing it and can't overthink
it too because once again i'm looking at
this guy's youtube channel
i'm watching his videos it's like
they're funny i'm watching them
like what's unique about them well uh
they're funny you know that's what's
unique they're like they're
you know maybe i could you know do a
super deep dive critical thinking on
this but it's like
they're just good they're cool they're
good it's good it's like that's
sometimes just the level you need to hit
and that that sometimes
is the unique element which is most most
things
aren't good you know like food is a good
example if like
if i got 10 random items from anywhere
and we all tried tastes of them i'm
pretty sure
maybe not even one would be good like
you know like dirt metal
carpet you know uh
some dust lint you know and then
maybe like a single cheese it is one of
those random
of ten items you know
and then we're all everyone's like that
now that one was good and we're like
yeah
that was a rare find i just imagine
somebody wants to start a youtube
channel and they come across this video
and they're listening and they're like
okay dust
cheese it i know but like somebody
seriously but
i mean it's just that that's it it's
just trusting that it's good
you know like yeah but good is very
subjective anyway
if you want to learn about good i talk
about the word good a lot in our
functional filmmaking course because
i'm actually legitimately curious and
interested about
this idea but seriously
what is good how do i mean obviously
there's an angle so you could like
you know what no one's doing a show
about
crypto art every week you know it's like
wow
there we go you want to make a youtube
channel right now that's maybe a
good idea because that's a brand new
thing but you have to be into it
but you have to be into crypto art yeah
right i mean that's that's key it's like
you gotta be true to yourself and
it kind of comes down to making things
quote-unquote good like
you fi there's also nothing more
disappointing than like hearing like a
musician you're like
damn this song is just this song is
awesome and you go and you look them up
and they have two songs and that's one
of them and you're like oh
i guess i'll wait two or three years
until they release an album and see if
they're actually any good you know it's
like
you don't want to be that like don't sit
there trying to make your breakout piece
and you don't have anything else on your
channel or anywhere it's like
you need to be making it because you
love it and it needs to be coming out
consistently
well that's the thing that comes back to
all right you're trying to make it in
2021
consistency is key yeah right so
that's that's youtube loves that
consistency and frankie you gotta get
that critical mass
and the consistency you you never want
people
to stop thinking about you
never stop thinking about me
don't ever let me out of your mind don't
ever
be trapped in your mind i want like
chains on my wrists then i'm like
trapped in like i'm trying to use my
buff muscles to set
myself free are you trying to pull the
insides of the wall in
oh it doesn't maybe i guess i'm not
trying to escape usually when you're
chained like that your
size of the wall in and i'm not breaking
these chains i'm i'm i'm just chilling
but i'm chained in your mind but that's
what consistency does you know you
release stuff
frequently and people are like hey i'm
coming back i like this stuff i'm coming
back
it's like yeah it's like serving an ice
cream sundae one scoop at a time
like and then they've been able to say
that algorithmically
on youtube now that's the other thing is
that they've actually
the data scientists and the actual
product engineers have been able to
identify
and and and actually commoditize
like digitally like
consistency in as part of their the
fabric of their
code you know and and so that's
i mean there's some really i mean
obviously it's google but there's some
super high level
data that analysis and and
in using it as an instrument to pull out
these things
um that that weren't going on
when we started for sure and so knowing
that like starting today
you'd yeah you'd want to be doing
something consistent
that doesn't cost hardly anything
that can uh you can continue to do
it for a long period of time without
much
effort because you're probably not gonna
make a lot of money off of it for
well maybe ever you know but when that
timing comes along
that that call it luck call it timing
call it circumstance you know when that
when that critical mass hits and that
timing comes along and then all of a
sudden the thing you've been doing for
three years
all of a sudden becomes relevant to a
much greater audience
than you know then boom then there's
your
success on the viewership side and
that's that trust
like you feel like you're doing
something cool you think it's going well
you know you know you think you're ahead
of your time a little bit you know it's
like well
you got to do it for a little bit until
time catches up with you
and everyone else's time meets with your
time which was ahead of theirs
and then right maybe then the algorithm
will give you 500 000 subscribers
yeah or you'll die before that and then
you'll go down as like a
an artist ahead of your time well i
think the other thing too like along
with being consistent
and being good which takes a lot of
consistency to just get there
like even now like going into a video
like i generally know if it's going to
be a good video
but sometimes you're kind of still
shooting in the dark but that's okay
yeah but that's the thing it's like you
know there's the
the like you know you talk about
inspiration and stuff like that there's
like
yeah inspiration is cool but like just
craft and like
going all right well like we're making a
video
it's going to be a video when we're done
like yeah maybe it's not the most
inspired thing in the world but like
being able to repeat that process and
fill in the gaps when inspiration
you know is is lost i think is really
important that's that's the work yeah i
mean but so yeah the first step which is
consistency but then the second thing
you need to do
is you need to constantly be tweaking
something you know
if you make a video it's a hundred views
cool you make another video
it's a hundred views cool you make
another video it gets a hundred views
cool
all right when you make your fourth
video what are you going to start
changing
yeah you're not going to get it's not
going to change unless you change
i'm going to try a new character i can
try a new storyline i can try
a different color grade what what's the
thing that you're going to do
to start evolving because you don't
evolve too fast you also like
you know don't just make something
completely new and not out of the blue
actually not
screw it you can if you want to if
you're only getting 100 views do
whatever the heck you want
it doesn't matter but don't do the same
thing and expect things to change
if you're not changing and then also
it's hard to get to that point
too when you're when you're when you're
making it and you're putting all that
energy into it and
it's like those are the 100 views that
that you're getting
so i'm like can can you guys hit here
hear my kid crying
yeah very family faintly
but it's hard to see the force from the
trees when you're in that moment
because you know you're like okay should
i keep doing this
but it's true by the time you get three
four videos into it and it's exactly the
same result
you know yeah you got it you got to
think okay
something different well that's the
problem with the concept of formats too
it's like formats are cool only when
like they're doing something it's like
it's successful in a way
yeah i mean it's like yeah like do a
format if you think it's important
that the format like the format is the
important part and the thing you enjoy
go for it but you know that's why it's
important to mix things up too
just like you know don't start a format
until the format's been proven
you know there is no format until you
have success with a format then you have
a format
other than that that was one of the that
was one of the weirdest things about
youtube
that isn't stigmatized with it today
that was a stigma when we started which
was
no one knew what to do with it uh it was
it was okay is this television
is it a game show is it a
reality show is it a movie everyone was
remember all like every time every time
we had a meeting
with people who wanted to dev
something or or you know take what we
were doing and and
more it was this constant
just education guessing game
of people trying to put the parrot the
pe
the platform into a box that already
existed yeah
and it just it wasn't any of those
things it was a little bit of every
one of those things but it wasn't any of
those things and i think
with when new platforms arise like that
like people don't necessarily know
what to do with them like yeah now we
can just we can go and we can just call
it social media
tick tock oh what is it it's social
media instagram what is it social media
youtube what is it
social media but each one of those
things is
completely unlike the other one you know
in terms of what's popular on it who
uses it
why why those people use it why those
people view it
how those videos get shared like totally
separate things
um we're just you know more advanced i
think at
doing doing those platforms quicker now
because there's
there's you know everyone's got a phone
yeah that not everyone had a movie
theater
or a television in every house or in
every hand
back in the day so let's let's
return to the question once more let's
get really focused now okay
specifically corridor right me
you jake and sam yeah
we just got out of college we've been
doing the same thing we've been making
cool videos for about
eight years now uh we can do some vfx
we're basically
all kind of like peter at this point
right um
okay we want to make sick videos how do
we start
well i'm gonna say there's two paths
forward
i would say that the first and most
obvious one mostly from hindsight
is doing something along the lines of
the vfx artists react show
because we have no clout yet we have
zero clout to my surprise
to my surprise a lot of people
that i've seen either commenting or even
meeting in real life
have mentioned that they saw that show
first
they're like wow that show is cool and i
figured out you guys
also made other videos after that like
that was
the secondary element which was oh i
just like watching these movies
being explained like i like seeing these
cool vfx shots and then having
having someone yeah just you know pull
the curtain back a little bit
like that it was just that and so
you know using the knowledge we had then
like we could still kind of
do this show still like we have way more
experience now but
even back then there's still a little
element of like hey we can still go hey
this is 3d it's just compositing tricks
green screen stuff you know not as well
but we would still be able to pull it
off i think perhaps
i i feel like we still need a couple
years of doing it under our belts
to be able to talk about it to the
extent that we're able to but maybe
i mean i feel like you know i feel like
you still kind of need to return to the
same thing which i think holds true for
everything that goes viral because you
take something
that people like and you give it a new
twist that only you can do what's your
unique perspective
on something that people already love
whether it's a video game
you do a cool cinematic you do a little
spoof a little comedy spoof
or you're going to do a little movie
parody we're going to touch upon a genre
that people like are going to do a real
life like
hey isn't it tough talking to girls let
me give you some tips you know whatever
like
but what's your twist right what are you
gonna do that's brand new
that applies to the thing that's already
been done um
or something that's popular sorry
another that's already been done what's
what's your twist to something that's
popular
uh and that can be from an established
ip to just
a classic genre that people like like
horror movies you know a lot of
a lot of movies are still successful
because horror movies are a genre that's
still very popular
and you just do a twist on it you know
horror movie with a twist boom you got
yourself a new successful family
i was thinking about this i really want
to shoot quiet place with farts soon
oh my god like the opening shot is just
a guy
whose face is super red and he's
sweating
and then it turns out there's two people
who've been holding their farts for a
very long time
and this is the moment when one of them
might let one out
and they can't fart or else the monster
will kill can we okay
stop stop let's start editing this next
week
this is so that would do so well no no
no i got the whole thing
written i got all the gags i honestly
was thinking this is this is a casual
like
one person with a camera two actors
maybe one additional person to chill and
hang out with us
and wait i thought okay we couldn't film
it we could you couldn't film an
original
but i thought you were just talking
about re-editing the movie
no no no no no because i i i i live
next to this place um where's the story
going
no no i'm not going to say where the
place is but i have a i've got the
perfect location
it's completely empty it's a huge
area that's empty and we can film it
it's
really close to my place like we just
roll up there
film it it'll be super quick and like
hilarious
yeah no dialogue i suppose there's no
dialogue it's just people like getting
angry at each other
like and
[Music]
he would be so funny in this
wes and clint and just let him go to
town
oh yeah no it's just two really
furiously angry people who have to fart
anyways okay there you go all right all
right
so you've established your art right you
establish the thing that you're going to
do
that's yours and it's your own but it
also touches upon something that's
popular
but it brings your unique perspective to
it okay so you got your unique voice
you're doing the quiet place with farts
right
all right it's the second thing you got
to do to launch your channel at least
that i would do if we were launching
quarter in 2021
so figure out how do we get the word out
there if the algorithm is not going to
do it for us
how do we do it do you first start off
by just grinding out some good work as
long as you can you meet some people you
stay in the industry for a year or two
and then maybe do a collab with somebody
who has a bigger audience maybe that's
the way you get the word out
maybe you focus on doing like a really
viral like series of videos where like
you focus a specific like fandom or
demographic for a while
um until you like start getting shared
around those circles
you know maybe you're hitting up i would
uh i would
take um a similar approach to what we're
doing with the corridor crew
like specials now um but if we were just
starting out
apply that to people that are already
successful on the platform
and try to get their attention yeah like
you know you you take it
you do a corridor version of like a
david dobrik video
or whatever you know um and and
you you make our version of that like
interpret
interpret their work through our lens
yeah and then get get the attention of
the people that are
watching that to to go ha ha hey that
was funny but then
the next time you make one they
recognize a pattern and they go hey this
is just like that other video that i saw
yeah oh there's this whole thing and
then yeah they hit you up and they're in
one but yeah basically that's your way
around the algorithm is to reach out to
people that have an audience
and have them just directly connect
their audience with you which is
actually not that hard to do
um people are really chill and like it's
not that big of a deal to
tell your audience turn on your audience
to somebody else who's doing cool stuff
i mean that's
that's one of the beauties of the vfx
react show is like we're constantly
getting to showcase some cool animations
and cool things that are being done
yeah yeah you know like that's a really
viable approach to getting a start but
you have to have the body of work
the next thing that i would do while we
were working on that body at work
is i would take uh
like a true vlog do a true vlog almost
um maybe not in the sense of like what
traditional youtube vlogs were
but every day be like shooting
and then following storylines and then
releasing
releasing those story lines you know
once or twice a week
in in a in a more like in-depth that
here's what we're working on
sort of perspective but then also take
clips and snippets of that
and put it out across multiple platforms
too not just even when starting out
my only worry with that is that why
would anybody care about your day-to-day
life like what makes it special why
would it be
worth documenting you would take the
viral stuff
and and and put that out and then once
people click
on that then hopefully get them to
connect with you
on the stuff that
is more daily as it leads up to each one
of these releases
i think the thing that gets lost when
people think about vlogs and daily stuff
is like you still need to tell good
stories
just documenting your daily life isn't
going to
interest anybody yeah that's your daily
life hundred percent i tame tigers like
okay then i'm interested i'll watch
i still hold the opinion that vlogging
in public is
um is impolite i would agree
i think if you are vlogging or hanging
out with people
and like you're in public filming
yourself doing stuff and talking to a
camera
and or you're hanging out with friends
and you start filming yourself for a
vlog segment
i think that's like that's like socially
inappropriate
yeah i maybe i'm being misunderstood
here when i say vlog
i don't mean like this
i i don't i i mean take a snippet of
what's being done and
share it and
oh my god it's so long ago i can't even
remember the dude's name
the first vlog on youtube like the first
true vlogger on youtube
is this big big dude
um shay carl shay carl
yeah yeah um i don't mean that
i don't mean like do a shay carl yeah um
you know
you do you not have any more recent
references you can use for that
no i'm i'm just i'm i'm drawing i'm
drawing back on
when we started i'm trying to draw
correlations
it's basically 90 of them but they all
they all took that format
um but anyways no i what i mean is like
you you take a
you take a you take an insight
people people see the people see the
iterative work
with the new twist on it right and it
has that 80 20 rule it's 80
familiar 20 new they see it they're
drawn to the rest of the work
as soon as they discover you there's a
body of work that that is similar to
that
so they're like oh okay cool cool cool
cool great this is this is all great
where what do i do next and then you're
like hey you know
now here's
how we led up to this process here's
where we got the idea to do this one
here's where we got the id to do that
one and then from there you can leverage
into
you know like a series that's just based
on
like it reacting to
something else that's out there or or
another more iterative like re
repeatable format that you could do
and also i think the being being
consistent at least across
two platforms today even if it's the
same work
you know um even if it's that same end
product
having that consistent across two
platforms i think today's
is really important because people don't
cross platforms like they used to
sure yeah i mean you know like one thing
though in talking about all this stuff
you know we talk a lot about it we talk
about these deep dives and our thoughts
on
filmmaking the stuff that we use to
guide our work and
you know like i was thinking about this
this morning a little too which is you
know there's no such
thing as film rules there's just film
tools basically
in the sense that like the reason
there's no such thing as a film rule
it's because like
you're saying that like this is how it
has to be done
you know but the thing is is that
doesn't discount what's being said
you know the reason they're film tools
is because there's multiple paths here
that you can take to use this stuff
there's multiple ways you can utilize
these things that we use
or you hear from other people you know
they don't even have to be implied in
the same way
it's like they're good to know and be
aware of and to experiment and try them
out on your own
but you know you don't want to box
yourself in too hard and like close your
mind to the point where you're like oh
like this is how things work you know
because
that's you know it's it's a very
subjective place here
so yeah yeah yeah and
you you've always been good at calling
out that stuff sam when you feel like it
we're getting to
call it out yeah i know like i just just
we're getting too close to like just
you know doing something that's already
been done i guess or
or doing something because hey that's
how other people do it
um and that's that yeah that sense of
creative trust
in yourself is is really important it
takes time to develop
i mean there's things there's things in
life where you want to follow those
rules like
building a house you know a lot of good
rules
a lot of good rules a lot of mistakes
before you
yeah you know there's there's things
there's things but yeah
right right but houses
don't evolve and change as fast as media
platforms that's for sure so
yeah not in not today's day and age
that's for sure
um so that's it that's sam sam you can
make
sandwich sam would make if we could do
it differently guys in summary
sam would make a quiet place with farts
nico would make
nico actually you didn't did you go nico
did you give one
i mean did you say do you remember
anything he said i just i don't know
i don't know how to conclude it i guess
i just in conclusion i'd do it the same
way we did it
yeah no no that's what you're saying
which is like
find things that you can give
your spin on and ideally those things
are are popular things because once
again
we are talking about youtube and
technically youtube is a social media
platform meaning
you're not just releasing media into a
void you're releasing it into a space of
communication that goes directly between
you and the audience
and that's why it's social so you know
it seems kind of like trite sometimes to
say hey let's make an avengers parody or
take a scene a quiet place with farts
but you know at the same time what
you're doing is it's you're you're
tapping
into that social half of social media
yeah to
find success and i think that's totally
totally valid i mean you don't need to
define
everything based on that but it's it's
good to play with and experiment with
because you can quickly reach people
who might want to watch your
style they like your style and the way
you
show them that style is by starting
with something you have in common yeah
right yeah that's even though that just
results very well i think even that guy
i keep that joel haver guy you know i'm
looking at his videos
he has videos that are about like video
game jokes there's like this
you know there's rpg stuff there's thing
you know like yeah there's a lot of
originality but you know once again he's
doing that too and i think you could
pick that apart and kind of
find a lot of stuff we're talking about
in that content as as as uh
how everything kind of worked out i mean
if your art's not going to comment on
the human experience then what are you
commenting on
yeah i mean that's that's that's one of
the reasons why i think danny gonzalez
uh has been able to have such
success is because it's his
you know dry danny humor
with a oh is that a is that a kid
screaming in the background
he oh yeah brother what happened
oh bonks all over the place man
do you guys hear that that's a bomb oh
yeah i know
so yeah podcasts are dope
2021 is sick here it's like 20 20 but
just a little a little more
uh sounds like it's under control now
okay
um yeah but anyways like yeah um sam i
think that sums it up well
uh you know thanks like
no i don't know what you said about the
other parts yeah the other stuff like
you're utilizing a common experience to
get people to be to be interested in
viewing what you have to offer
yes yeah so yeah basically then also
what nico said which is the same thing
we did
we would just have to update it would
all slightly change an update but it's
kind of the same tactic
yeah and we still have to grind it out
for ten years before we have a hit show
you know it's like the same thing
happens
still gonna grind same situation the old
video grind
no video game yeah it's been a good
grind though
it is definitely one dude i'm still not
happy to be on that girl definitely not
going to [ __ ] with twitch
twitch that's a time sync
all right well uh i think that's it i'm
going to play us out do you guys have
anything else to offer
to the to the true
i'd start a tick tock channel where i
just look in the mirror and try to do
pretty poses for all the girls
pretty poses for all the girls
there you have it that's the secret to
success
nika went out and he started a tick-tock
profile
now what else did he took pretty
pictures for
all the girls and then
he
[Music]
and then he quit youtube and just went
full time tick tock
full-time tick-tock nico's making a
killing
he is he's got them gold hey you can
fade out at any point christian
go ahead yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh lord all right if you're still
listening
god help you thanks for listening
all right uh subscribe bye